so for what value of c or values of c
is
x minus 5
is x well let me write it this way
for what
for
what
c is x minus 5
a factor
factor
of
of p of x and i encourage you to pause
the video and try to work through it and
it's p is actually a lowercase p p of x
all right so i'm assuming you have
attempted this and we just have to
realize okay if x minus 5 is a factor of
p of x that means you could write x you
could write p of x let me do this in
that green color that means you could
write
p of x
as being equal to x minus 5
x minus 5
times some other business times some
other polynomial
so times
times some other polynomial i don't know
let's just call it g of x maybe
g
of x and this would be well it would be
a second degree polynomial
and so what would p of 5 have to be well
p of 5 would have to be 0. 5 would have
to be a root of this polynomial you see
it right over here if you replace
if you replace this with a 5 then this
is going to be a 5 and this is going to
be a 5. it doesn't matter what g of 5 is
this is going to be 0.
so if f x at x minus 5
x minus 5
is
is a factor
is a factor
if and only if
if and only if
p of 5 is equal to 0
p of 5 is equal to 0. you could say that
5 is a root of the polynomial p
p of 5 is equal to 0. so let's just set
p of 5 equal to 0 and then try to solve
for c
all right so we're going to get 5 to the
third power so this right over here 5 to
the third so p of 5
p let me just write down p of 5 is equal
to 5 to the third is 125
plus
2 times 5 squared so it's 2 times 25
plus 50
plus c times 5 plus 5 c
plus 10 that needs to be equal to 0.
and let's see if we add
if we were to add
125 to 50 to 10 we are going to get 175
185 so we get 1 85 plus 5c
plus 5c is equal to 0. subtract 185 from
both sides you get 5c is equal to
negative 185
negative 185 or c c is equal to negative
185 over 5 which is going to be
it's negative 185
over 5 which is equal to let's see 5
goes into 180
let's see it goes into what's five let's
see it's gonna be 30 5 times 30 is 150
5 times 30 is 150 and then we'll have
another 35 to go so it's going to be 37
negative 37 is that right 5 times 30 is
150 5 times 7 is 35 yep negative 37
and we're done if this was x to the
third plus 2x squared minus 37x plus 10
then x minus 5 would be a factor of this
polynomial